all right i'm calling my dad to let him
know that i'm buying a lamborghini
according to graham welcome to the 31st
ever
episode of the iced coffee hour uh
my name is jack doherty and we have made
23 359
doll hairs so far so uh yeah let's get
into it well
welcome that was impressive that was
pretty good i can't believe i did that i
used to say that all the time when i was
a kid like i'll pay you five doll hairs
i didn't say dollars this is doll hair
my english teacher used to say that all
the time so that's why so are you still
in school well
how about this jack you want to yeah
yeah let's introduce him so your name is
jack as well
and you're 17 years there's a little
difference though in in our achievements
though you're 17
and apparently you're a millionaire
yeah okay so you're apparently a
millionaire at 17. you have 3.2 million
subscribers on instagram tons of social
influence on youtube on youtube oh sorry
on youtube
sorry and uh apparently you have tons of
social influence
and you just reached out and you asked
to come on the podcast and i talked to a
few people
and i knew we just had to have you on so
welcome to the podcast thank you so much
for coming on
thank you and uh yeah it's really
impressive that uh what you've been able
to achieve
uh to date yeah i mean i love watching
graham's videos because
i believe it wasn't for graham i'd have
i would have blown so much money oh my
god like
geez like i probably would have been
spending like i spent two or three years
ago so
thank god i'm not two to three years ago
so you were like 14
15 years old like the money was like
really new to me so i was like kind of
being really generous with it like
buying everybody gifts so i've been
thinking about this for the past few
days now like i want to know
how much money you were making at each
age
how cool are you with disclosing numbers
yeah i mean i'm cool with it because i
feel like
oh that's my stock alarm it's okay my
bad wow a stalker one
stock alarm neo's a five percent got all
right
but uh the pump has commenced no no but
uh yeah
i remember my first like month i
literally remember the exact amount i'm
pretty sure like the first month i ever
like took home a check was like
three hundred dollars like and it was
just like dang like it was in december i
was like probably
13 or yeah i was 13. and then
ever since from there's gotten bigger
and bigger and bigger like every single
month so
like my biggest month was like 140 000
and i was like 15 i think and how did
you get all of
that revenue well first of all how do
you because it would have to be under
your parents yeah everybody's under my
parents name yeah like everything i do
like the stocks every parents are paying
a lot of taxes on that yeah
i mean yeah they are but uh um my dad
helps me with everything like my dad
like if i buy a house like everything's
under his name i kind of screwed over
his credit but
he's uh taking one for the team to help
me set up my future so
yeah what made you start making youtube
you started just making youtube videos
yeah i mean like my first video i was
like 12 like a week before i turned 13
so like uh
i started posting like trick shot videos
and stuff like that whatever was
trending like that's what i would like
kind of hop on and
i started like just doing whatever was
trending and that really worked out for
me from the beginning so
did you go into it with the idea of
becoming famous on youtube
no it's like literally like a video i
made in school on my school i've had me
flipping markers and stuff like that
that was like my first ever video
and i was like dang i want to post this
on youtube and then ever since then i've
been like super consistent like
when i first started i used to post a
video like literally every other day
almost like i was like
always filming and it wasn't like like
stressful you know like it was just so
easy it was like a breeze but like now
you kind of overthink everything like as
it gets on so yeah i've seen recently
you've been posting it's like three
times a week right
yeah so you've got a in graham's mind a
perfect schedule that's a good start
three times a week so you start making
youtube videos at like 12
13 years old when did you start making
money from it
like kind of right off the bat like
maybe three months after i started like
i
worked on monetizing it like after a
couple videos i'd say
and then literally like i think in
february i had like my
biggest video like blow up and that's
when like i was like dang like this is
serious because
i went from like 3 000 subscribers and i
was like away like skiing with my family
and my friends and
the next day i was at like 15 000
subscribers so it was like a huge deal
like my channel like
literally over quadrupled in like less
than like 12 hours or something it was
insane whose idea was it to monetize was
that your
that was yours everything i do is like
mine like my parents never really
like were involved in it like i know
like people i'm like staying with now
like
all their parents are involved with it
like coming up with video ideas for them
like doing all that but like
my parents support me mainly and like i
kind of i'm left to do like the work i
guess
so you wanted the money back then like i
didn't really do it for the money you
know like
i was having fun with it but like if
you're gonna have fun with it might as
well make money on top of it you know
yeah so
it's great it's it's a great source of
income wow
and then you kept posting videos what
were you making at 13 years old
um like mainly just like literally i
would flip bottles and like just
trick shot videos like that kind of
stuff because that was a trend for a
couple of months i think yeah
so you trend hop and then you found like
the youtube algorithm that way or the
youtube
yeah i found you yeah so like whatever
so i went from like flipping water
bottles to like floors lava challenge
videos that's like my second biggest
video
like that one has 15 million and like
the one of me flipping random stuff is
like 27 million views
excuse that toy like gosh i thought that
was screaming
i don't know if you can hear it in the
background you definitely can gosh
it's a little flapper in the back of the
toilet that
[Laughter]
gosh if it doesn't stop in a second i'm
just gonna go over there sorry about
that
all good so at 13 you were making like
viral content
yeah were you like like methodically
putting out content that you
thought would do well with the algorithm
were you just doing what you would you
like have fun
no i kind of knew all like the videos
would do well because it was like such a
huge trend at the time like everybody
was posting these videos like dude
perfect like
it's one of their biggest videos also
like if you did that like those types of
trends
when that was like trending like it kind
of like blew up your channel like that
was like the time to hop in
to youtube i guess it's much easier to
happen to youtube i think three years
ago than now you know
because like there's way less
competition three years ago so
that's what i thought though i thought
three years ago it's too late to jump in
because there's too much competition
yeah i mean i guess in three years we'll
be saying that now right
yeah we're gonna be looking back now and
be like oh it's so easy back then
there's no competition and yeah
it's just it's gonna continue to get
harder so i just think the sooner you
start the better
yeah i agree i mean yeah if you guys are
trying to start youtube
start right now so so while you were
doing this you kept just
growing the channel um what about 14
how did the content evolve over time um
from what i remember it was just like i
was just hanging out with my friends
like we would just always film videos
like it was super easy like nothing like
was like scheduled and just everything
would just kind of flow and just happen
and then over time it started becoming
like more like
i guess organized and like planned out
like what videos i'm gonna do what day
and like
sometimes like because of school like i
still am in school right now so like
i'll film like
on the weekends mainly or i'll come out
to california for like a week and a half
or something like that and like just
grind out a bunch of videos and get all
my videos for the month or something
like yesterday i filmed
three videos for my channel like four
other videos like other people's
channels and then like
the day before i filmed three videos and
like another three videos or someone
else's channel like
i just go so hard when i come out here
so i could just go back home and just
kick back
why why go to school um at this point
so you can see are you in high school
though yeah i'm a senior now but
um i'm i should be in class right now
actually
but um this is more important than yeah
100 like i
especially am out here i didn't even
plan on going to classes but uh
like your school just lets you skip like
this no
they don't they just mark me absent but
uh i don't really
you don't care at this point i don't
really care like i'm i don't know if i
should be saying this
but i don't really i don't do my work
i'm not going to complete uh
i hope no one sees this maybe we catch a
drift we catch your team yeah
yeah i'm not putting anything out like i
i do my work it gets done you know so
it doesn't matter how it gets done yeah
it just it gets done
it gets done yeah it gets done so why
not just go for like a ged at this point
get it get it over with like i don't
know because in new york i don't think
you can uh
just i don't think you can take a test
or anything to just pass
can't you just legally drop out can't
your parents sign a forum and be like
hey just not going to school anymore i
don't know can we because now school is
like taking away from you
yeah yeah there's no sense actually i do
i've made
so much content around school like oh i
guess like
some of my biggest videos are skipping
school
and my mom my mom hates those videos for
like i mean god do she gotta do the
first video did super well
so like now it's like kind of like a
little series to have in my channel
where i skipped school to do
stuff so my most recent was like
skipping school to get the iphone 12 or
something like that oh that's good
yeah so i got to like monetize me
skipping school and getting the iphone
12
so i made the money back back on 12 so
that is next level and the year before
that i did skipping school to get the
iphone 12
and then and then i did a second video
buying my whole family the iphone 12. so
i got like two videos out of it
that's just like graham's videos like
that's 2019 best
stock market tips 20 20 best stock
market tips buying my family an iphone
in 2019
that's great yeah so who's your audience
who would you say is watching your
videos
i think the people that like come up to
me in public and recognize me the most
are like
probably like anywhere from like 10 to
like 15 or 16
sometimes kids my age like will come up
to me or sometimes older like especially
where i'm from like
i feel like everybody knows me because i
live like i live in like long island new
york so it's like
everybody kind of knows everybody there
so if there's like i'm like the only
youtuber there so everybody kind of
knows me you know
how popular were you in high school i
feel like you would have to be like the
coolest kid there to have a youtube
channel over a million subscribers
in school i mean everybody like kind of
knows me like
well everyone definitely does know me
but like uh i kind of keep my friend
group small because
of that you know you don't want friends
being friends for the wrong reasons
yeah yeah definitely not but like before
youtube like
everyone thought i would like make my
money like from going like the athlete
kind of route you know like i was always
like the athlete in the family like i
wrestled i played soccer like all my
life
i played like four teams at once at one
point like i played football i played
basketball
hockey like recently hockey and
wrestling were like my two big sports i
play golf i play like really every
single sport you could think of like i
was like the athlete of the family
so they thought i'll become like a
professional soccer player or like
do something like that but this all kind
of happened and i had to kind of drop
everything to continue this at what
point did you start making enough we're
like oh man now i
now i got to do youtube full-time um
well when i was like i think i think i
was 13 like the first month i came out
here
i made like 40 000 and then i was like
dang like
wait how old did you say where i was 14.
jeez
yeah but uh i flew like everybody in my
family out to california with me and
we came here film like that wasn't like
the floor's lava challenge video blew up
like that i gained like a hundred
thousand subs in like two days so like
that was like the crazy
what's that floors i played that game
before yeah you just like
it's just like a with like yellow floors
lava and like everyone has to try and
get off the floor and like
go on to like maybe a table or like a
chair or something like that so whose
house did you do that at oh we did it in
target and i went to the ball pit
like that was like the main thing the
video i went to the ball pit and like
the
the workers saw me do it and like kicked
me out and like i could like barely get
out of the thing like and i kind of like
felt like funny
but uh yeah that one blew up about like
15 million views it's at now or
something like that so
jeez yeah all right so we've got to do
man
the floor is locked why are you not
doing floors now no it's old now
it's you have to wait for the new trends
i don't really know it's trending right
now
kind of everything let's go back to the
to the money thing so you made 40 grand
um it's obviously it's going to your
parents so how do they divvy this up do
they
they don't take anything they don't
spend anything like my dad does well
for himself so like we uh we all kind of
he just helps me like invest it i guess
well i'm actually like
i'm i kind of do everything like i
invest my own and like stocks and
everything like i do it all
my all by myself i got options trading
everything that's probably the buzz like
i'm in like tons of different like
discord groups and everything
so yeah like i i started doing stocks
like
two years ago and okay so i've been like
trying to get experience like i've
definitely lost a lot but i've made it
all back and like
i don't know you just definitely learn
from your mistakes and i think i started
off with like way too much
so that's crazy you've done all of this
like just by the age of 17.
that just blows my mind that is that's
so young in my mind to have
accomplished that much thank you so
let's let's talk a little bit more about
the timeline so you started making
youtube videos
when you were 12. and then you were
monetized by early 13.
so it was basically like you could call
it an instant success
yeah honestly i kind of blew up really
fast and i feel like a lot of people
that try to start youtube at first like
it takes like a couple months and like
nothing will happen it'll just stop
but i was super consistent like the
number one thing for me was like
consistency like i would never miss an
upload like
i would like religiously just like
upload and never ever miss an upload
and why do you think you were so
successful so
quickly i don't know i feel like i just
had like a really good work ethic like i
know a lot of people say that but like
my dad like
taught me a lot growing up and
everything so like
uh like i was always like super hard
working in school like i got into like
the top high school
in uh in in my state or like probably
one of the countries actually like it
was like insane like i went to
like a program like all summer long to
help me get into it and
like that kind of that summer i kind of
blew up and i think i was like 100 000
subscribers
or something like actually no i was
actually way more than that i was
probably around like
a hundred thousand subscribers when i
had to decide but then by the time the
next year started we're like i would
have gone to that school i was around
like eight hundred thousand so
like when i was at a hundred thousand
subscribers i had to decide like go to
school or like continue youtube and i
was gonna make a video like
uh asking my fans like what i should do
if i should like go to
like this school and get into like a
really good college or continue youtube
and i'm so thankful i
i didn't even make a video and i was
like i can't be doing homework like four
hours a day
you could have made a video on it i know
everyone aged 10 to 15.
yeah hey guys yeah made your life choice
do you want to be getting kicked out of
walmart more or do you want to see me go
to school and go to college
or i'm sure they would have getting
kicked out of school yeah honestly
getting kicked out of school
but um we went to like the tour for the
call of duty college for the high school
and
i asked the kid like how much homework
do you get at night he's like around
four hours and i'm just like we're
leaving right now like there's no shot
like i have adhd like i can't even do my
own homework like
i think that's so stupid why why should
kids need four
hours of home yeah i don't even do one
hour home we're gonna do any homework so
like why can't i how can i do four hours
gosh like and i was like a huge
troublemaker in school like
like in elementary school like they made
me go on like uh adhd medication
or like they were gonna send me a
special school because i was like so
insane like
i was like always running around like
causing trouble or whatever because i
just had so much energy
so but now you film it yeah now i film
it and i use that energy
yeah genius yeah it's genius gosh so you
mentioned earlier
that you were blowing money how do you
blow money at like
14 or 15 like do your parents give you
full access like you make 50 grand
like here's 50 000 there's no way that's
responsible right
but first a quick word from our sponsor
audible so audible reached out to me to
sponsor the podcast and they offered me
six months of free membership
in order to do the sponsorship to test
out the product to make sure i liked it
and it was actually really funny because
i already had audible i was already
paying for it audible was actually the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment
and also audiobooks and they recently
added podcasts one of the main things
i've used auto before that was actually
really helpful
during college i had a lot of required
readings for each one of my classes
i just listened to it on audiobooks on
audible and that was like
way easier and it definitely helped out
my grades and if you're interested in
audible you're in luck because right now
they're holding their best deal
ever it is their holiday offer it is
only 4.95 for the first six months and
guys i'm so frustrated because that is
literally better than what i was paying
so if you guys want in on the deal go to
audible.com
iced coffee or you can just text iced
coffee to 500 500. it is as easy as a
text just text iced coffee to 500
500 or if you want more information on
this check out the description there's
plenty of stuff there
and with that said you guys back to the
podcast no but like i feel like my
parents like limited me
back then i wouldn't be where i'm at now
like i would always be like trying to
spend everything they would give to me
you know
so like i learned i'm sorry i learned
from myself like really young to like
not blow my money i feel like because i
would like blow down like louis vuitton
bags for my mom or like
buy like gucci stuff for me actually i
never really bought myself that much
stuff because i didn't really care
because
like my biggest purchase i would say was
like yeezys or something at the time
but you were making like yeah way more i
was making like two yeezys a day i don't
know
yeah what is that two years it was like
seven days ago yeah
1500 bucks a day 700 each oh
that was the biggest purchase i spent on
choosing like the 700 shoes but like wow
yeah
i don't know the price of yeezys so when
you say two uses a day
you gotta say things in starbucks terms
like how many starbucks literally like
probably a hundred cups of starbucks
maybe two hundred cups of starbucks is
paying higher all right extra stuff
you're getting
1500 to two thousand oh my god i
actually got starbucks yesterday i don't
know didn't think about it no trust me i
never do that stuff like i never do it
but i was like
i didn't even think about it was it
worth it no no i drank
it i was like i can't be having caffeine
try this yeah oh yeah yeah
jack made it for you so i did not make
this so if it sucks it's made the exact
same way right make sure all right
i use the og 20 centis coffee coffee
maker
so definitely way better than starbucks
good yeah so this is good and it costs
20 cents
actually probably less because there's
ice in there right
yeah like now i'm the type of person
that with my friends and i go out to eat
i literally will try and go to like
a certain place like i will not spend
like 30 on food like them i'm like no
way i'm doing this this is such a waste
of money i'll be like michael
you have dad's credit card michael's my
brother i was like you're paying for me
like
you're getting dad to pay for me i am
not paying thirty dollars oh my gosh
no we've changed you you've changed me
like i would i would take my mom out to
like the most expensive restaurant every
single weekend
and i was like and now you don't take
her out anywhere no now i say mom makes
me
feel you go out no i go mom you make me
food you stay home and you
you pay for you this is all thanks to
this guy right here
and my mom despise you [ __ ] that guy
that graham that's that's evil graham
that's how you could you start
monetizing your mom now oh i do that's
what she's the main person that's giving
school videos she's the one who gets mad
at me people stay for her reaction
is that is her reactions real yeah like
she's she's polish so like she
is like all for school like she that's
the only reason i'm still in school now
is because of my mom
yeah you could have a video like bossing
my mom around for the day
you have you done that i've done
controlling her life for like 24 hours
and she's done that to me also okay how
real is that
um everything we do in the videos are
real like sometimes like i think we get
like an entertaining thing i'll like
tell her to do something but like
honestly everything's pretty real like
like i've gotten suspended for my videos
and then i got suspended for skipping
school because i
skipped school and stayed in the
bathroom for the whole video and like i
would just i camped down the bathroom
skipped all my classes
and they saw that video suspended me for
it so then i filmed my suspension
and then they suspended me for that
again but out of school because
they thought i would film it again so
yeah they didn't want me to do that
with that yeah this is smart though
they should be promoting this if
anything like that is a badge of honor
to have a kid that goes to your school
that's
pulling in you know and doing what you
do but here's the problem the school
can't do that
because then every other day yeah every
single year and then
they're going to go out of business like
no school but right my principal
actually
is a huge fan of me so is my assistant
principal like they were like all
waiting for me for like to get on ellen
or something like they wanted
they like all supported me and
everything and uh we have a new
principal this year
and he like called me in and like my
son's a huge fan and like made me sign
something for his son and everything and
so yeah they're all chill could schools
do that like the principal will be like
hey
hey he's signed this from his yeah
there's some special treatments yeah
well
one of these you know yeah they almost
have to though because you're a special
case
yeah in this because so many people are
watching you that anything they do is
going to be filmed
yeah i'm going to talk about it so at
that point if i were the principal i
would just tell you like listen
don't go to school don't go here just
just do something else
we'll slide you by but just don't post
about us
sign this yeah i mean what do you do
after high school then
because don't do you feel like you're
growing up and your audience
you gotta like shift with them yeah
that's why i'm like
you know who knows that's why i'm trying
to like invest in like real estate and
like the stock market now like
i'm really trying to set myself up for
my future so i don't have to like
really worry too much but i'm always i
feel like i'm always gonna be doing
something like
now that i made money like so young like
i feel like i'm always gonna want to do
it you know because it's just in your
mind and like
it like kind of you if you grow up with
it like it's kind of like who you are no
i'm not saying like my
life is based around money but you know
what i mean like it becomes like an
accomplishment that you just keep on
wanting to grow and grow so let's hear
about your investment portfolio how
about this jack you want to turn the
cameras off and on
yeah really quick so i want to see what
you're invested in i want to see your
whole portfolio and then i
think you're swimming i could react to
it is it cool if you like this is like
any of this yeah this is my like actual
big account right all right let's see
let's see what you got
here she might be accountable i'm down
thanks guys
because i didn't wear a button-down
shirt today that's why this is like well
i
sell like i buy and sell so much tesla
like i was up like 20 grand
sold it all and we bought back all right
so let me see this so you got uh
321 000. yeah
sure so 321 thousand dollars in
robin hood do you want to is it cool if
you screen record this
sure i only have 18 000. i've been down
like
18 000 at one point like but i'm back
there we go so guys 321 000 robin hood
up and down up and down let's see with
three months ago
you're at 296. 320.
all right yeah i mean made a little
money so what else do you have besides
this you got 321 of robin hood yeah
you know what let me see what you're
invested in okay
no no because no just to like watch it
you know because but like
but like i've been like i've had all it
invested and i sold it all like at peaks
and stuff like that and then just like
like i don't know but i used to have
like a lot and everything and like be
very diverse but like i was like the
election and everything i kind of like
sold a lot of it because i was worried
but
oh my god you can't do that you can't
time the market
can't if you watch my videos you know
that man i know but like it's hard like
everything i'm gonna lose everything
really everyone thought the market was
gonna be going down
everybody and especially with the uh
the results of the election people were
a little bit unsure in the beginning
and the market start rallying so you can
never time it so we got some
yeah i made like 20 grand on tesla this
week and that's going back up
and i also just bought a tesla this week
last week we got to talk about it what
did you get
all right all right so you got some
speculative stocks some good ones i like
jp morgan a lot
yeah i sold a lot of my bank of america
is decent
stuff all right uh cheesecake factory
what did you do
because of you because you're like let's
see yep yep average costs
32. there you go and it's almost 40
bucks yeah i should put way more in
there
i love the cheesecake factory i don't
know how much more upside there is right
now but they were one of my best stocks
too
all right so besides this what else do
you have i have this account this
account i should have done with
with my robinhood account but this is my
fingertime up like
seven thousand dollars overall and i
started with 8 000
okay so you got 15 in this what else
what else in your portfolio
yeah real estate oh tell us about real
estate
my real estate so i bought my first
house i'm actually uploading the video
on that today
so i got my first house when i was 15
but i finally made a video on it i never
saw it until like literally two or three
weeks ago
first time yeah a rental where is it uh
poinciana florida
and then i bought a second house two
days ago
in idaho well i closed it like two weeks
ago and i bought
it in i in idaho and it's a duplex so
nice yeah so tell us about the first
place you bought how much was that how
much you put down what are you ready so
the first house i put down i bought it
with like this other youtuber i don't
know if you know
kris krohn heard of him yeah so that's
kind of sketchy like
he's so i put all the money down fifty
percent yup fifty percent yeah
i gotta start doing this guys geez so
wait wait so definitely
i'm not talking about this mistake but
um
so we i went there for uh the first time
in three weeks and
i see uh an eviction notice and see the
guy's missing
seventy three hundred dollars in rent
and i was like no way like this sucks
but um yeah so let's back up yeah
because now i'm really curious about
this real estate's might so i i will
know this stuff okay
so how did you get in contact with chris
to buy that place in florida where did
this how did this come about
um because i've been like i've always
been like in love with real estate like
ever since i was like super super young
literally i would watch
hgtv like since i was like like seven or
eight with my brother like all the time
like it's the only show you would watch
so i knew i always wanted to do
something with real estate and i saw an
ad on youtube
and of of him right from there she
should have skipped the ad but uh not
gonna lie but no hate to chris chrome
but
there's just a lot going on right now
because my dad's like kind of mad
because they never told us anything like
they're trying to like take have full
like
rights to the house or something like
that like there's just a lot of sketchy
stuff going on like i don't want to
say that yeah so you saw kris krohn yeah
reached out to him
did you talk to him personally or
someone yeah i talked to him personally
and he flew me out to utah with my dad
and he sat at his house i saw a video
he posted on his channel with you yeah i
remember
that wow i watched a lot of youtube guys
i see like everybody's videos i remember
that
same i see everybody's videos too i bet
you can name any youtuber i would
probably know
yeah probably but yeah so you so you met
up with him in person
yeah and then does he just hand you this
deal says here's the deal
or did you find the deal and go to him
um so i just
kind of put up the money and uh he found
the property and there was like a bunch
of different properties and we kind of
sort of choose it and they have like
really high cash flow properties
if they pay rent but uh so how much was
the
the place so i bought it i actually have
all the houses
i bought i have i could send you guys
this too yeah right here so
all right so okay oh we don't need the
address yeah um okay so you bought it
for 120
175 and uh
on 8 18. and how much money did you put
down on that
i put i think it was just over 70 000
down
on it and 70 000 so with like closing
costs and like everything included and
like
all that stuff okay and then what is
chris so chris says
i'm going to give you this deal here's a
deal we've picked
we're going to split the cash flow 50
50. yeah i'll manage it for you i'll do
all the work
all you got to do is put up the money
but i'll take 50
so it's 50 50 but he'll do all the work
you just provide the capital yeah
got it okay what did that house rent for
uh 14.50
okay so all this tell you on the surface
yeah buying a house for 175
that rents for 14.50 i don't know the
exact area
from the cash flow perspective that's
fine yeah i don't see anything wrong
with that
yeah so that was uh what two years ago
yeah how long has the tenant not paid
the rent for
like 7 300 divided by 14.50 so maybe
five six months five six months okay
and you can't do anything you can't
really evict them yeah until the end of
the year
yeah um that's the issue with some of
these places like that and that price
point
is those tenants are not as financially
stable yeah
as some of the better areas yeah but
then i bought this duplex and it was a
completely different deal like i bought
it with the youtuber chandler david
smith and yup
he found me the duplex um
doesn't take any percent of it just
wanted like to film some youtubers with
me in exchange
and yeah i think i think it's a really
good deal like i bought it for
180 188.5 and uh
the down payment was like 47 something
and because he managed to put the
closing cost
like we just paid extra for the house
and so we wouldn't have to pay extra in
cash up front
so like that kind of just gets added to
the mortgage and so that like definitely
helped me with the cash flow and
everything and
i like this deal way better like i'm not
sure because chris we have a call with
him
on like monday to see either if i'm
going to buy him out or he's going to
buy me out because we just don't want to
do the deal together why don't you just
sell the house
that's what we're figuring out on monday
and what we're going to do but i looked
it up on zillow and the house
estimate is like thirty thousand or
forty thousand more than i bought it for
so
i would honestly if you sell and just
get your money
back yeah consider that a blessing yeah
consider that like
you know easy on that one yeah i
wouldn't keep that it's definitely a
learning experience you know like
i'm glad i learned these uh lessons
young yeah so here's the thing though
i'll be honest with you
this is not worth your time to manage oh
100
so yeah so i agree with you not going in
and like doing any of this work yourself
putting up the capital i like that
but um not for 50 like a property
manager like an expensive property
manager is gonna take eight to ten
yeah maybe maybe sometimes twelve if
they're like
full service um but even then
honestly like i think on the idaho falls
house it's like uh
six to eight percent yeah that's that's
fine yeah and what do you think you're
gonna be getting on rent on that one
that one
right now the rents are currently six
and six fifty but we're raising them to
9 uh 50 and like 750 or something okay
so it'll be close to like around like
it'll be sixteen hundred dollars at
least
yeah or 1700 i'm going to tell you to
sell that first house because here's
what's going to happen you're going to
evict this tenant well really quick guys
we have a word from our sponsor
nordvpn nordvpn is a great service i use
that basically provides extra security
when i'm browsing the internet a couple
things right off the bat that nordvpn
does is hide your ip address which is
actually public information and it shows
exactly wherever you're connecting to
the internet from additionally it will
also hide whatever domains you're
connecting to
from your internet service provider so
basically spectrum can't know whatever
weird websites you're looking up online
this doesn't apply to me because i don't
look up anything weird online but
anyways that's besides the point nordvpn
provides over 5 500
really fast servers in over 60 countries
to make sure you have safer internet
browsing and now when i'm banking online
because let's be honest
online banks are the best it's nice to
know that nordvpn has my back and
basically will just act as a secondary
source of security nordvpn has your back
and i strongly encourage you guys to
check it out if you haven't already
because right now they're holding a huge
christmas sale where you can get 68
off of a two-year plan with four free
months guys
this is crazy it's awesome you should
check it out i love nordvpn
you guys would like it too thank you
guys so much get that christmas sale
and back to the podcast uh that's going
to be the tough part
yeah um because it could take a few
months to get that tenant out
and there's no telling what sort of
damage they're doing in that house so
what you're gonna have to do after they
move out you're gonna have to fix it up
now you have an empty house if you rent
it out and decide to sell
later you're selling it with the tenants
in place it's gonna be harder
so you got a good little window right
there where the tenant's out
you fix it up it's all clean looking
that's the point to sell
yeah i mean i definitely i'm gonna use
that advice
on the phone call that we have with him
so yeah you know what the good news
is that it sounds like you're not going
to lose money yeah that's the most
important i mean
he said either he's going to buy me out
or i'm going to buy him out but like i
don't think
i should be buying him out if he didn't
put any of the money up front you know
like i gave him a lot of return i bet
you i brought him people to buy more
houses with him and make him more i want
to show you so
like that was kind of the whole world
but he wouldn't just let you because
that's the agreement right you signed an
agreement saying yeah he has
50 is it controller ownership
is he untitled they're trying to get
yeah they want they're trying to they're
trying to do that like they wanted to
like
they were kind of like rewording it to
try and get around
like saying it like that because they
want to like kind of get ownership of
the house
like and have full control over it so i
don't know i'd be curious to see
what they what they what sort of
agreement they have because if he's not
on title
i i don't know that might benefit him
not being untitled with all these plays
with a mortgage because he might be seen
as a bigger credit risk
for his company versus just happening we
bought the we bought the house under
my dad's credit like everything's under
my dad like my dad helps me with all
this like he does all the documents yeah
uh like literally filled out like a
hundred pages and had to sign like over
100 pages just to
like especially the idea for idaho falls
house because like every time you buy a
house in a different state
you have to use like a completely
different like i don't know
company to get the mortgage from so wow
imagine that every deal i did as an
agent i'm just like hey
50 that was mine yeah right all your
money
are belong to us that's insane
definitely
yeah i feel like growing up making that
much money at such a young age
people might be kind of like predatory
yeah
yeah just because you're young and like
doing so well yeah i'm thankful that my
parents like never took any of my money
because i know a lot of kids that got
into youtube and
their parents quit their jobs and now
yeah i'm not saying there's anything
wrong with that like they definitely
help them like i would i wish i had
someone to help me like that and like
just take the stress off me
but i kind of have to figure that out on
my own and like you know
was your dad telling you that was a bad
idea with kris krohn or is that you
pushing it
sort of he was i was really pushing like
i really wanted to do it but like
because my dad does real estate himself
he has like
15 houses or something like that like
and he didn't tell you like hey we're
not going to do this
yeah well he just wanted you to do he
likes he's a firm believer in like
learning from your mistakes but he knew
like if i got into this house i won't
really lose money you know
his money on that he was just like yeah
he like was like jack like do you sure
you want to do this like yes dad like
this is a huge opportunity like
because i was not gonna lie i was kind
of manipulated by the whole idea of like
chris cronin like what he does but yeah
so
gosh i mean i don't know because at
least you're not gonna lose money
that's the thing at least with this
you're not gonna lose so and it's a good
lesson
uh that didn't cost you really anything
i mean you missed out on some profit
but and relative to your income like any
loss that you could have
incurred from this i'm remonetizing it
from the video yeah you're really
monetizing and at the same time it's
like
not the biggest dent yeah but he also
takes fifty percent of rent
yeah that's another thing too yeah after
the mortgage i think
so like like whatever it's profit
oh it's a little okay i was doing the
math in my head and i was thinking like
oh
yeah yeah plus i guess in your in your
tax bracket it's not like yeah
and they also like they cover the like
the chris actually covered the
first couple months of like uh when it
was vacant or something like the first
month or two
when it was vacant like uh of the
mortgage and everything so
yeah that was that was helpful that was
nice of him to do
hmm nice to get fifty percent nice to
get fifty percent awesome all right
uh 50 house houses he has because he
doesn't buy anything with his money it's
like always other people's money which
is i mean which is key he's probably
making a fortune oh yeah definitely i
mean i have a feeling
he's probably making well over a million
a month i'm guessing he has to he has to
be
i mean who knows because i might be
ending the deal with him soon so i don't
know how many people i'm going to deal
with him you know
because they you realize how much fifty
percent is once yeah
it's like i will defend him here
that it's up front fifty percent like
you know
going into it hey it's 50 you know what
you're giving up yeah definitely so
whether or not i agree with it there's a
lot of fishy stuff going on behind the
scenes like of them trying to get like
they want like full rights to make all
the decisions for the house and
everything like that
and my dad is like smart enough to say
like no i get it
part of me defend him again on that part
of me gets it because if he doesn't say
that
he's gonna have a bajillion people each
like i don't want the color of that room
to be painted
white it's got to be an eggshell and
then dealing with people back
like you have to have control over those
decisions
i think it was something like more
important than that and the pain
i don't know there's something i don't i
don't remember exactly what my dad told
me but
yeah because yeah from a management
standpoint if you're getting input from
all the people and arguing back and
forth and coming to compromises it's not
efficient
yeah so you know but i would have to see
the exact agreement
but uh i i would side with him on that
but i don't know the situation exactly
yeah i mean it's a lot i'm trying to do
like a lot of investments right now you
know i really want to set myself up for
my future
so i'm really trying to get more into
real estate now because my dad when he
was like in the 80s he bought like
uh houses in new york for like 80 000
and now they're worth like six seven
hundred thousand so like
that's what i'm trying to do you know so
that's what i'm really trying to get
into
yeah that's smart and you're doing it at
such a young age that like
pretty much whatever happens you know 30
40 years from now you should be all
right
yeah i mean there's always like new
content ideas like who knows family
channel in the future i don't know like
there's always stuff that could happen
so
is that what you want to do at some
point family channels those
oh my god anything with the relationship
kills insane you do so well
i don't get it i don't know either i
don't know why i don't like those
channels i feel like all i
really do are buy like is buy new homes
yeah like i just see like oh the z
family's new home like yeah
i'm like i saw this like last month uh
yeah then it's pregnancy
pregnancy right right and then viral
viral yeah the funk bros i'm really
close with them yeah
uh he did caper and funk just got
married uh they had a pregnancy video
and
like easy one million plus two million
view two million plus video viewed video
or whatever fudge i don't know what i
just said
but uh yeah they like they have a couple
hundred thousand subscribers like their
family channel or whatever and
video got ten times more views and they
have subscribers yeah and you know what
yeah it's awesome
haley uh pham and ryan yeah their
engagement
just like every four million views yeah
that was like number two on trending
because they're so young might have to
hop on that are you so are you going to
find a girl and then just like have it
just like
yeah yeah imagine that it said that's
viral
that is viral all right i'm gonna look
into it i got it i got like what
ten eleven more months of being
seventeen so wow yeah and eleven so you
just turned two yeah like last month
yeah no it's december now oh my god two
months ago almost
jeez time flies yeah yeah i feel like
you gotta hop on that train because once
once you're 18 it's not it's not it
doesn't have that punch in it well i
guess 18 does
but 17 isn't 17 is like yeah exactly i
got one more year of doing the crazy
stuff i do
because i got like arrested like two
weeks ago what did you get arrested for
i did a fake beer but like they let me
go they detained me pretty much for an
hour they said
they fully uh convinced me i was going
to jail and like they were and then my
dad said something on the phone that
made him like let me go
but do you think maybe they're playing
hardball because you're 17 because
you're a minor they're not going to put
you in jail like you can get away with
more now
oh yeah when you're 18. yeah 100 that's
why i know that
yeah i've gotten away with a lot of
stuff like a lot of stuff
so so what else do you want to get away
with while you're 17
oh i don't know who knows uh maybe get
arrested a couple more times
we'll like detain a couple more times
yeah but uh
hopefully nothing too bad happens what
do you get detained for now
um well let me see what have i gotten
like a lot of
really like the i say the most trouble
of like the closest i've ever come to
getting
is like that fake beer prank like that
one was insane like i did that in
florida
and oh my god like that was like the
scariest thing about my dang i'm
actually going to jail like i was in the
back of a cop car for an hour like
it was the scariest thing ever i was
like in florida they would just be like
yeah you know
they were so mad like they were really
mad and i was like
dang like i just this is now or like
actually this is double like i'ma
monetize this you know
but at the same time like not to be like
that but you know what i mean like
but it's great content don't you show
them the channel don't they when they
see your youtube channel with all the
subscribers
don't they aren't they just like aha
that's funny no
um actually like the first two cops you
did she thought it was really funny and
then
i messed with the wrong cop at the end
because i try to like get a reaction out
of them you know i was like dang this
isn't going like i want to get a good
reaction so
i pushed it really hard and too far and
yeah how did you push it what do you do
i was acting really like drunk even
though i wasn't you know i was just like
i had like the fake alcohol and i was
just going crazy and they were like
fully convinced i was you know
i was under the influence or something
and and then right when i
put my hands behind my back and like put
the cuffs on me i was like
i went back to being sober it was it was
so funny but like looking back on it it
was definitely like
the most perfect reaction ever like the
most like couldn't have gotten more
perfect but
how do you one-up it from there because
i feel like now you gotta keep you gotta
yeah but are you too nervous at the same
time
if you keep pushing the envelope like
who knows what could happen a few years
down the line someone looks back at some
of these videos and see
you know sees how you acted and yeah
couldn't there be some damage in that
like wouldn't you want to also
take a little bit of slack back and like
yeah i mean
there's not many people that are doing
like crazy stuff on youtube nowadays so
i feel like i kind of have to like go
down that route
but at the same time i don't really like
getting in trouble and like because my
my dad's actually super chill with it
like he was like so calm when i was in
the back of a cough girl he really
like is can he because he knows like
that's what i kind of do for a living
like the crazy stuff
but um that's just like my kind of my
youtube side but then i do have like
that business side so you know like i'm
not like really like i
i don't enjoy getting in trouble but you
just gotta you know make sacrifices for
the videos i guess sometimes but
um i've gotten like punched in the face
by a walmart worker and like broke my
camera one time like
i said when i was 15. can't you sue
isn't that yeah
i've done so much stuff in walmart yeah
it's like so much like it's insane but
that that's just a small sliver of the
overall pie if you got punched by a
walmart and playing
video too at fifth oh oh off on video on
video like i was holding my camera
takes my camera like you know the g7x
like yeah
crushes the lens shot like just
literally smooshes inside
camera's done and then but the sd card
was chilling so i got all the video
and then my friends that i was with uh
right when my camera broke they started
recording on their phone like of me
trying to get my camera back because i
started like streaming their name
because this guy was like attacking me
like
taking me to the ground it was like that
was a crazy moment i was like
but every time i have a crazy moment
yeah every time i have a crazy moment
like that i'm like dang i really gotta
chill out like
you don't think that that's your ticket
that's like that's that's a three
million dollar settlement right oh
oh honestly i talked to my dad about
that i was like dad this could be the
way out
this could be it no no like the ultimate
we were working on it we were actually
going to like
go but like my dad's really not the type
of guy she like he doesn't like
suing people i don't know i feel like
you can't like go into walmart cause
like ruckus and stuff and then
try to see it because they would come
right back at me yeah like at the same
time like you've gotten so much out of
them and if you're doing stuff like
like uh i don't know instigating yeah
exactly like pops and then like
doing not gonna be the like in walmart
then finally when something happens to
you you're like oh yeah
yeah what are you gonna do about it i'm
15. that's not true it's like you did
instigate like a lot of this yeah so i
think that
you probably made the right moral
decision by 100 percent right moral
decision financially
yet to be even though it won't affect
walmart at all like that's just like one
day of sales for one of their stores you
know
not even yeah they have insurance for
that i'm sure they have lawyers on
payroll they have a fund
i'm sure they're still dedicated that's
what i'm saying
like i mean he probably should have yeah
you shouldn't put like punches yeah
i was such a little boy i was like yeah
i don't know but
like i feel like if i were to try and
sue them for that they would try and
swim for
everything i've done and their team of
lawyers is just going to be insane
oh yeah 100 like it would cost it would
rack up money for
both sides well mainly our side but uh
that's true
yeah that's you usually they would offer
a settlement that's usually you got it
on video it's like
that's pretty okay how often how how
long after can i how about this uh i'll
coordinate
all of this but i take fifty percent
okay sounds good
what about me my idea ten percent forty
percent
all right all right yeah that's fair
that's pretty
that's pretty crazy i see you like the
twenty-six i thought it was amazing yeah
it was great
good it's good yeah all right so besides
those investments
do you have anything else what about
like cash on the side
uh i do have cash inside like cars
just waiting oh yeah just bought a tesla
actually did you buy it uh the model 3
performance
cool which one do you have model three
just like yeah i
don't know performance yeah but that's
why i bought the a tesla
because like i saw your video on 78 yeah
and and so what i did was that's what
i'm trying to buy like a tesla
house like where i call my tesla house
because it's going to pay off my tesla
you know
because i like uh i'm gonna and i also
put all the money that the tesla cost
because i'm financing it
so i could uh i put it all in tesla
stock and i'm gonna have that like
pay for it also you know so you're
trying to get the cash flow from the
rental property to pay for a tesla yeah
that's exactly what i want to do yeah
that is awesome
that was awesome key that's very smart
so how much uh how much you do now on
the channel
um i see your analytics yeah oh i love
can you screen record
sure so are you are you similar to car
share
because it seems like his videos that he
posts a long time ago continue to
perform better and
like 80 of his revenue every month comes
from videos he posted
more than a month ago are you the same
or is it like i feel like
yeah like my videos do you get a lot of
views over time but like
i feel like my comments are disabled on
youtube like
because i'm underage so that's like that
made
that's like the most pissed off thing
i've like it's so much frustrating thing
ever because
comments help with the algorithm so much
like like
it stops my videos like from getting
like views and everything
i feel like after a while because um did
you
go to revenue and stuff yeah 660
something that's
insane man but first a quick word from
our final sponsor of the podcast
flexispot now i don't know if you guys
have noticed this but i'm actually using
a different desk than i've used before
and that's thanks to flexispot i decided
to go with the 55-inch
en1 mahogany standing desk but they have
plenty of other options as well
it's awesome when i start feeling lazy
and i feel like i need to stretch out
the legs i just press a button
and all of a sudden i could be standing
and working at the same time they also
sent me this chair and i can
confidently say this is the comfiest
office chair i have ever used so if you
guys are interested in a new setup i
strongly encourage you to check out
flexispot there's a link down below in
the description so click that
they're holding a sale right now and you
can get 50 off any desk
so it's a great deal i love the desk and
i think you guys probably will too
thanks so much for watching and back to
the rest of the podcast
yeah wait so all of your
comments are disabled yeah there's
nothing
it's just because you're 17. just
because i'm seven well because they did
it to a lot of channels that were under
age because like
yeah yeah you can't say that the p word
gotta meet that market
47 30. did you ever have any issues with
like creepy comments or anything
no that's why i like i've argued with
them so much and they're saying that
there's nothing they could do but
then charlie amelia on the other hand
has her comments uh enabled but
it was because this whole thing happened
um two years ago so
every channel like two years ago that
wasn't created now yeah
like so but now if i create a challenge
channel like my second channel
uh since i never really posted it on it
like i have comments on that but like
just because they flagged my main
channel i can't have comments and it's
like the most frustrating thing like
i've spent
like hours on upon hours like on call
with youtube like
on do like the creator support which
doesn't help at all and like
it's just so frustrating all i want is
like the comments that's why i premiere
my videos now so
it's the closest i can get to comments
oh yeah with the live
chat about that because i said you had a
video premiering later today yeah yeah
that was that was a video on the house
i just uh well the house i bought a year
and a half ago but do those videos not
do as well
what do they typically do justice no the
uh
the the house stuff i don't know i'm
testing it out so you've never done it
before no
i don't know why like i never uh i never
posted the video
because i never really saw the house
because i never had the time to but
um yeah now i'm finally doing it so i'm
gonna see but hopefully it should do
well
i think it would because like the title
is like how i bought my first house at
15 so
i think a lot of people have been in
teams yeah you got to do something like
calling it disturbing the neighbors
throw in some sort of like
it's gotta be frustrated or something
yeah yeah it's trying to get a jacket
dirty video huh yeah
yeah definitely i have to let me edit it
right now oh yeah you know what and if
the tenant
trashes the house that's another another
video yeah 100
tenant traffic it's kind of a good thing
if you're a youtuber yeah yeah meet
kevin does that any issue with his house
it slides off the foundation
yes you know what my the funniest the
funniest
comment i saw or the funniest video he
did is he was going through one of his
rental properties and he
titled the video i found a dead body
in my rental house i kid you not that
was the title
everyone clicked on it the death the
dead body was
a rat oh god in the attic
it was so funny and then he changed the
video because dead body got like
shadow banned so he changed the video to
i found a skeleton
jesus that is so sorry
he pushes the envelope in the finance
community yeah
yeah i heard he's a whole different
breed like he is just go go go awesome
yeah work 24 7 and like i don't know how
he manages to post that many videos a
day like that blows my mind
and like how he edits them himself too
and like they're so like the
the editing is so good on them like it
blows my mind how he does that yeah
like i have an editor now also so
because like i it's just too much to
handle for me you know yeah
like bouncing school like uh the videos
and just like
everything is just so hard to do with
like and and manage to edit like i used
to edit all my videos
and now it's just like i can't like it's
just too much for me and i never will
edit my videos ever again like no
i just can't yeah another one of kevin's
videos that i i loved the title
this is in my opinion when his titles
were at his prime it was
i left my family for a model
and that was actually the title of his
video but
yeah but yeah the plot was he left
he didn't buy a single family home but
he bought a model home
and he left his family for a model yeah
kevin and kevin is
we're gonna have him on at some point
again but uh
definitely i think the star of youtube
right now just his work ethic
everybody i i've not met one person
who's not like really impressed by what
he's doing
yeah that is absolutely insane how he
made like a million dollars in one month
on youtube i can't believe he did it two
months
too two months two months over a million
dollars really
yeah damn oh two months in a row uh i
think so i think it was two months in a
row that he did a million
that was like because of the stimulus
stuff right stimming stuff but i think
he had some other stuff going on too
but uh but that's not even including
stocks
so like i know this year he was telling
us like four million bucks in tesla
stock
like dang imagine we could have like a
like what like a 10 million
a year you think uh with tesla's like
with stock gains
yeah including stock gains yes yeah
eight figure year yeah
with stock gains i wish
10 million dollars yeah dude but here's
the thing the stocks could go down the
next year but if we're talking about
just like what your gain is this year
i mean that's insane props to him that
is crazy
geez yeah that is that is my dream i
want to actually start like a financial
sort of channel because like
i'm young so i feel like i'm trying to
i'm working on it with my manager like
because i have to like balance my main
channel you know like i really have to
focus on that but like
if i were to start like a financial
channel i would want to hire someone
like full time to like come up with the
ideas and like
like help me with this like video and
everything like edit and post it because
i have to like mainly focus on my main
channel because
that's what got me here so well i think
that your audience would be really good
to teach about finance because they're
like a younger
demographic yeah i feel like introducing
that to them at the young age is like
really helpful
and like i feel like a lot of kids want
to know how to make money like it's
pretty like exciting to make money at a
young age yeah definitely i think so too
that's why
i hope that real estate video on my
channel would do good because i feel
like people would be interested you know
it'll be a good test it would yeah it
would if it doesn't do well though i
don't think it's the video i just think
it's your audience
yeah it's really tough to get uh to get
that audience interested in finance
it definitely is but like the cpm's in
that industry is insane
yeah like i have a pretty high cpm for
like uh
for what i do because i know people
because i'm not that like family
family-friendly like there's like
cursing my videos and all that stuff and
like i just do like crazy stuff but
like there are people like that do super
super family-friendly content that i was
actually just filming with yesterday
and their cpms are way lower than mine
for some reason and i have no idea
maybe i don't know i kind of go hard
with you what are your cpms uh like
seven eight that's decent for that
channel
yeah yeah like if i get like on my on my
videos now if it gets like 500 000 views
i'll
make like three four thousand dollars
off it so it's pretty they're pretty
good it depends on the video though
definitely
yeah i think though if the finance
doesn't take off for you i think just
you gotta get a relationship yeah i
think that's like the next step
yeah monetize that family right exactly
get a relationship
buy new homes and have more babies yeah
buy more homes and hammer babies and
gender reveals and gender reveals
yeah totally yeah you could even do like
uh the blind dates
the binding oh yeah so like a series of
trying to find the wife right yeah
and then uh the video of like you know
the gen reveal all that so i'll have
like a leading up to it monetize all
that
to pay for everything in the future and
then you know all the extra divorce yeah
then divorce and then do it all over
again it's like a circle
yeah every couple of years just keep on
circling you don't have kids with the
girls if you're
what okay what gets more views though
the engagement videos or the breakup
videos
i'd say the breakup videos the breakup
videos are because there's like no way
yeah like they're crazy the engagement
one i feel you can wait because like all
right you already know they're engaged
but like the breakup one you want to
know why they broke up
so yeah jeez
crazy how it works every single time i
go in trending it does seem like a yeah
we broke up
all lowercase period at the end yeah
mike malek
yeah and then they got back together
right afterwards it's insane
luckily that was so much money i believe
that was real though
but yeah did that not work to his favor
faking those
i saw she tweeted out um everyone's like
why are you letting mike keep up that
video she's like i'm trying to
i told him to use ad revenue to buy me
christmas gifts he's smart
smart yeah she's so funny but she blew
up his channel like without
i don't think without her do you think
it's her or do you think it's
logan paul oh a hundred percent her
because uh mike was doing
youtube when he was with logan paul but
like he never uh
but he never blew up like that like that
was insane like so when he as soon as he
met lana
uh he went skyrocket every single video
three four million views it's insane
like more than logan actually you know
what's crazy
uh what i heard this is a rumor the
reason why
logan and and jake and some of these
youtubers were using
p stars like you know i did like but but
no no
okay yeah we're going to sleep that out
no p stuff p star no we don't have to
bleep that out
okay um is because what they would do
like um like riley reed and
that that group is so many people were
searching that online
that if they put their name in the
thumbnail or
sorry if they put their name in the
title they would rank
so when some person is googling the
internet
finally read it's not you know those
videos that come
up it's logan paul yeah that's you you
have to find
really close honestly so yeah that'll be
that'll be added to the series i guess
yes yeah definitely crazy stuff genius
though
honestly that's next level like i would
never think of that
but it's our next guest on the podcast
oh god
you gotta get them on my journey man we
would our seo would be
i think that's fine might kill the [ __ ]
might kill the cpu
and it's educational and we're bringing
to light a subject
you know we talk about the financing
yeah yeah that would be interesting i'm
sure a lot of people would be very
curious
yeah but all right we could try it
definitely we got a lot of these
especially you brought those two on as
long as it's got content i'm in
i think that would be yeah it would be
interesting yeah i'm bringing them in
yeah there we go there we go it's genius
so let's let's go back to your income
over time how you've scaled it
um where like how is your income divided
what are the different sources right now
that you have
so right now it's youtube is my main
income
then brand deals and like stocks real
estate like so
those four are like my top and then i
have like uh i have
two hundred thousand invested in like uh
ten percent return like guaranteed
so that i can't that's compounded
monthly wait what
how how did you do that you could might
so my dad seems yeah
there's no way 200 000 10 a month no
time
no not a month a year yeah but it's a
high rise in like philadelphia or
something my dad
uh my dad's my dad plays a lot of golf
so he knows like everybody so he's got
me like so many deals and stuff like
that hard money loan
uh what do you mean that how is it
invested
i have no idea but it's got to be a hard
money loan is it being built or what
i think it's being built or it's being
rented out or something like that i
don't know but it's it seems like to me
that's a hard money loan so you loan 200
grand yeah i have no idea
my dad kind of just hangs there's
probably a term to it then yeah yeah
maybe
i'm guessing that's what it's got to be
okay so 200 yeah so my dad helped me
with that
there's that there's 200 grand invested
in that and so
uh that's one thing and then what else
i'm not sure i think that's that's like
one of the biggest things i have so
uh yeah and then we have a good
corporation that like that's where all
my money goes into
and that's how i get like paid pretty
much okay into there
so and how is your income changed over
time let's go over your annual income
since you were 13.
so since that like in my first year
youtube i
i uh from when i started to like in
like the the first year i made like 700
000 subscribers
but uh when you were 13 or 14 13. okay
so yeah i hit like 700 000 subscribers
so i probably made like
maybe 100 000 maybe a little more than
that and then uh
probably more than that actually but uh
yeah then every year it's kind of
growing like my i think my highest year
was like a year ago
because uh i like my i like had a bunch
of videos blew
up in like november and december and
that's when the cpm's are the highest so
like
like i remember i made a video and made
like 40 000 or something like that was
like
one of my highest paying videos and like
uh that one yeah so that one
really like set me up for the rest of
the year because like it blew up my
channel and like my cpm was just insane
then also
but yeah ever since then it's like been
like minimum probably like half a
million a year
so with everything maybe more do you
worry
about the channel like not doing as well
no because i've had times where like
it hasn't done as well but i've always
like bounced back i've always just done
something crazy to grab people's
attention and it always has ended up
working out so
yeah i go through the same phases where
things kind of go through a lull and i
know that like
usually that happens for a few months
yeah you just got to push through it and
then i almost see this is like
so bad i just see this as youtube like
purposely testing me
yeah you're like let's see what graham
has we're going to give him like a few
bad months
and if he if he could get through these
months then we're going to reward him
with a big video
poor graham only making 200 000 this
month oh god graham's going to struggle
this month
yeah 175k yeah
wow geez but 20
iced coffee only only one couple
definitely one cup a day what is he
gonna do
yeah but uh but yeah i don't know
because you i i don't i don't i don't so
much look at the money anymore it's like
how are these
videos performing what's the i like the
growth that's that's all i really like
this it's just yes
how is it growth is yeah because well
with growth
comes more money so yeah what about
other social medias like you have
tick tock yeah i have like 2.6 million
on tick tock also
and do you do like brand deals or how do
you make no i actually don't make any
money on
time why because it's just like it's so
hard like there's so many
are you so many other people that are
not 18.
oh wait but how did charlie demilia
she's not a part of she does like brand
deals outside yeah and that's her main
thing
yeah she stands out on tick tock so much
like brandon's gonna go to her so you're
saying because she's not 18
she can't be a part of the creator fund
yeah it's their largest
she's she would be making probably i'm
guessing from that fund
maybe like 5 000 a day yeah she
well you know what she would eat up yeah
because even some live videos
i'm still doing like one to five dollars
a day on my thing which is
nothing what's the um the cpm on tick
tock
point zero zero zero two
[Applause]
yeah but how many
billions of views at this point does she
have oh my god
i can't even imagine she probably has
like
over 100 billion views because she posts
so much every day and
and everyone you have to think she's
probably
realizing she's she has to be getting
i know this sounds crazy she has to be
getting like
a billion views a month oh right
easily i say she gets 100 million views
a day maybe even more than that because
we're
like 50 million views each yeah
sometimes four or five videos a day wait
a hundred million a day time say well
that would be
300 million so plus all the backlog of
the other
let's say it would be three billion a
month sixty thousand
six hundred thousand i think yeah cause
cpm is a thousand wow i'm missing out on
something dixie you're getting that back
well here's the thing they're funned i
don't think it's enough to pay her this
because it just their views go down the
creator fund for those that don't know
is like something that you can enter
once you have a minimum amount of
followers and you get paid a flat cpm
regardless of what type of content you
put out i think it's like a flat cpm of
two cents per thousand
that's cool though they did that yeah
to make fun some of the creators because
i know like like if you're successful on
tick tock it's not the same as being
successful
like instagram or youtube because there
are so many people that do well on tick
tock 100 percent you guys
know people see you for like 10 seconds
each tick tock you know
it's not like you have that much
influence on people yeah it's true
and you can't tell what like who the
person is or something buy a tic tac
like
yeah you go to other platforms to see
that exactly yeah
have you found that tick tock has been
good for other reasons aside from
monetization like i'll see uh if i take
taxes well it'll help my youtube videos
so
yeah so we've recently been paying this
guy to cut clips out of the iced coffee
i were to post on an iced coffee hour
tick tock
and we're now seeing uh if it like
transfers any views to youtube or
something like that
i actually have i'm doing the same thing
with my tic tac i'm paying someone to
make the tick tocks for me like cut up
like even my old videos from years ago
and like i had a video from like three
years ago in walmart and
posted like last week i thought like
four million views like wow so
like that definitely helps out like my
youtube channel so so what are your
biggest expenses
month on month i don't have much like i
live with my parents so like
maybe traveling but i'm traveling to
film so
close i don't buy much clothes like i
got a lot of them for free
but what about your business expenses
um probably legal fees yeah legal no
insurance not really my dad kind of
helps me cover all that
because everything's under his name you
said you have a manager yeah
so let's talk about that like what
percentage do they take whatever they
bring me
like if they bring me a deal they'll
take oh it's just like a sponsor agent
yeah oh okay yeah but uh yeah if he
brings you like a deal and you get like
uh 15 or something like that fifteen
percent's pretty average yeah ten
fifteen percent i think
mm-hmm but uh yeah i think my biggest
expense
probably maybe like my dog or something
or actually now it'll be my car
yeah of the car that's the dream being
17
drawing driving like a tesla mall three
with my dog in the back with your dog in
the back you did it all yourself
dude no expenses what about when you're
18 do you want to move out do you want
to get your own place you want to live
with your parents
i mean i love home like i always miss
home but like i feel like like
as soon as i have the money i think i
will just move out
but like no i'm telling you no but i
think for content purposes like what
would i do you know
live with your parents like i could
probably get a police out here for free
like with like other
like youtubers and just live with them
yeah okay so if you do something like
that yeah yes but yeah i definitely
would not blow like
four or five thousand dollars a month on
run like i would not do like that's just
yeah because
tv thing because like yeah make a
creator house and then yeah yeah
like monetize that youtube channel for
the creator i mean i think if you have
an opportunity like that to move in with
other people do it
but if you have another year or so with
your parents mm-hmm
yeah i don't know i don't know what i
want to do though like after i graduate
high school or whatever like
i don't know like what the route is
because
i don't know it's just it's a lot to
decide you know more of the same
right yeah just keep making videos yeah
are you on cameo
nope i got kicked off because i didn't i
forgot to do my uh cameos
and i kept they kept on expiring and
like after a certain amount of strikes i
think you get kicked off are you serious
yeah but i didn't i didn't mean to like
now i'm trying to get back on it because
i see how much
like money you can actually make but how
much are you charging back then i think
like 20 bucks
oh how much well you got to charge an
amount where it's worth your time to
actually definitely do
i agree uh for those of you guys that do
not know cameo is an app
where basically you pay for a
personalized video shout out from a
creator
and it's just like a flat rate and
there's tons of people on there creators
athletes movie stars
but uh how are you charging uh 189.
damn yeah that's too much money i feel
like
what do you what do you do you just like
what are people like if someone were to
pay 189
what are they getting like what are they
normal it depends what the request is a
lot of people want me to say like little
things that they could put
in their youtube videos like you know
smash like button or
um i've been getting like someone
someone might have closed like a big
deal or something and their co-workers
like graham just go and congratulate him
on the deal
um all of mine are public though if you
go to my cameo i think everything i've
done
so far i think it's been like eight of
them in the last two weeks is all up
there so you can just see eight of them
in the last two weeks that's like a
thousand bucks
yeah something that's pretty good yeah
so i heard like carol baskin
was making like 90 grand a month off it
or something when that whole thing was
popping oh
dude i can only imagine the requests
carol baskin was getting though right
that people were like just confess yeah
literally and she probably would just
like send him like some random video
like yeah
has nothing to do with it just to get
the money yeah she's probably just up in
the charge and up in the charge yeah
tell them that you did it yeah right and
she's probably
yeah exactly exactly that's really
probably what she said she probably
wouldn't even
read what they wrote at all wow
[Music]
yeah but kevin o'leary is charging at
1200 bucks
no way yeah that's like the top grant
cardone i think is like 300 or 500.
yeah business guys the way that i see it
it's like if it's not worth your time
you know what i mean why would you
charge an amount that isn't worth your
time yeah and at the same time as that
it's like
it is nice to put yourself on cameo
because then it gives people another way
to reach you although
yes it could be expensive it still isn't
worth your time but like it's just it's
an
option you're not forcing anyone to do
anything yeah but what is giving you
what is worth kevin o'leary's time 1
thousand bucks rally still isn't even
worth his time
i don't know he's probably maybe 1200 i
don't i feel like even 1200 doesn't
guarantee you that he's
gonna accept it yeah yeah yeah and at
the same time
like there's so many periods of time
that like people just like aren't doing
anything like you have two minutes in
the day you're like oh honey stop eat a
banana
yeah yeah let me make this cameo pay for
that banana
exactly yeah well it's not favorable it
takes you out of the headspace though
because
the cameos aren't exactly easy it's not
like i just flip on the thing
say it one take and send it off maybe
that's you i bet you i spent a while
i've redone one for like 15 minutes once
before it was
so bad because every single time it was
a little bit more intricate what they
wanted me to say
and i kept saying it over and over and
over and over again and i get like a
minute and a half and because here's the
thing with cameo you can't do cuts
it's one take so i can get a minute and
a half in and then mispronounce the word
and be like
starting i don't know i got a cameo from
my friend yesterday like he's on cameo
and he wanted to be in it and
he just kept on redoing i was like dude
you could get on this in one take you
have to be perfect like i'm not a
perfectionist like that like in other
aspects yes but like
certain things have been have to be done
certain ways but like if it's like
cameo yeah you don't want to sound too
scripted you know so like just do it the
first take your second take if you
really mess up but
i don't know like in my intros like if i
mess up i'll just like i won't restart
the whole thing and i would just like
bounce off that
really it's really i think it just flows
so much better if you just
say whatever comes you know i don't like
this whole scripted thing but like it
obviously
to me it sounds crazy when i do it but
like when i listen to other people it
doesn't but like you know what i mean
yeah i don't know i just like everything
when it kind of just flows off it's not
going to be perfect
that's the difference like i bet you on
cameo you would have been like pretty
cool with like most yeah whereas graham
i feel like
he would want to export to imovie do the
cropping yeah zoom in when he makes a
mistake or whatever like
no way now it's not worth his time after
all that that's why
yeah yeah but yeah i put a lot of work
in that
so for anyone that uh is interested just
grab stuff and cameo
there you go you get a cameo link in the
description link in the description
below where you can get your
for free stocks from weevil and we will
yeah
do you get a stock every time someone
signs up mm-hmm no
i get a combination sometimes it's it's
free stock sometimes it's money
so it's like they'll pay you to promote
them it's uh i mean
it's an affiliate so the same as any
other affiliate okay yeah
he doesn't even know how he gets the
money but he really talks and money he's
just yeah
i feel like at this point it's more
exciting to open up the stocks and see
which ones you get
i like the stocks it's a lot of the same
uh like levi's jeans i got a lot of
levi's jeans uh i think is is bc
um what else did i did i get sw
yeah it's been a lot of the same yeah
but uh yeah
so yeah those cheap stocks huh well not
cheap
under under 12. yeah yeah under 12.
something you know it's better than
yeah you get a couple four stocks you
send yeah you get four free stocks
like basically twenty percent return on
your investment literally pretty much
yeah if you want to make twenty percent
you guys just wanna do that all day long
you can probably make a living from now
but you need to
stock accounts are hard to make yeah
yeah so well what else do you want over
an hour 20. yeah i mean like yeah i like
the whole income what's your net worth
um probably one and a half million maybe
more than that
a little more than that probably do you
have mint what's that oh my gosh
personal finances it's a personal
finance tracker and it basically
organizes all of your expenses yeah and
it can calculate you i don't have many
expenses that's right
but at the same time you should do it
now because the longer you have it the
better data
oh yeah mine goes back like eight years
yeah so we'll show your net worth
over time like on a bunch of different
ways you can graph it it'll like make
pie charts of all of your expenses
categorizing them so you can have an
understanding obviously like there are
some kinks with that like so what do you
how does it like work
you like link your robinhood account
where you're basically yeah
it's parent companies like intuit which
does the turbo tax oh yeah i trust them
so it's it's cool yeah yeah that's cool
i like being able to keep track of
everything yeah and like
do it now yeah it has your credit score
on it and everything as well i don't
have a credit story oh i can't wait till
i'm 18. i can get all that i'm gonna buy
somebody
but your parents would be able to put
you as an authorized user on one of
their credit cards yeah but i i still
can't build up credit for myself like i
have a credit card
in my own hand no yeah you can't i've
tried everything
yeah no if your parent puts you as an
authorized user they can
put those up because it's under their
name yeah because it's under their name
it only will help their credit
like i really can't no i'm i'm almost
positive when it comes to this
because now you're an authorized user of
their credit card so their credit
is going to transfer to you and you may
be a transfer maybe when i'm 18 but i
just can't have credit right now
not you can't like i can't i'm trying to
provide your own name
but your parent can put you as an
authorized user on their card yeah
didn't yeah that's right
yeah yeah she did like this
it's my card that's my dad's company
yeah and then check your credit that's i
don't have credit like
i have my capital one i literally can't
have credit
have you have you tried your credit
karma i've tried everything
like what does it say have you yeah have
you gone on credit karma though and
looked up your credit score
we have the whole finance community
watching right now uh
no i don't like i've tried literally
everything um
you have to be 18 year old to take
advantage of credit wise yeah credit
wise but that's just incredible
range uh that's just um one of capital
one's
algorithms yeah i mean i've tried like
to buy houses under my name i've tried
to buy the
the like finance a tesla yeah well yeah
that's going to be that's going to be
difficult but i'm saying as far as
credit is concerned
you should be able to build credit being
an authorized user on a parent's credit
card
i i've we've looked at we've tried
literally everything we've talked to
absolutely everybody and they said it's
only going to
i might be able to transition like it to
over to my name i'm 18 but like i really
like i can transition
like my the me financing the tesla over
mining but i can't like
have that yet like i really can't build
my credit really yeah
literally when you're under 18 one of
the options is to get an adult to add
use an authorized user on one of their
credit cards
you can hold and or use the adult's
credit card but you won't be the primary
card holder
yeah but it doesn't say anything about
building credit yeah the primary
card users responsible credit card can
help boost your credit when i'm 18.
no no you lose 17. this is what this is
what macy's uh
parents did for her really yeah
so you can have a credit score when
you're under 18. it's not like it just
transfers once you turn 18.
yes no no it's going to show up it's
just you can't open anything in your own
name
yes you can only do much of it you can
build it up that's what i'm doing pretty
much though then right
i i'm guessing that's what you're
already doing yeah you can't check your
credit like that maybe you have a score
yeah you just can't see it yeah you turn
eighteen i'm almost positive that's what
they're doing yeah so yeah i guess
that's what i guess yeah yes you are
building credit
yeah all right so ooh i'm really yeah
you're doing that
yeah i mean i like to pay attention all
that like i when i turn
uh i'm going to get a bunch of credit
cards and i want to buy a bunch of
houses
good a bunch of branches
[Music]
no not that no definitely not i'll live
below my needs
but uh no like i think i'm definitely
not gonna ever
rent like if i do move into like a big
house or whatever i'll have i'll move in
with people and i'll have them like
cover the mortgage or something like
that you know
i definitely won't pay rent or like i
would like to build equity
in a property instead of paying rent
right it's smart yeah
when's lambeau time oh never i don't
want to literally
oh maybe in a couple years down the line
but like not anytime soon because
i can't really drive like wouldn't
wouldn't that give you so much content
that like carter was saying like his
lamborghini paid for itself so many
times no way really
yeah and i i think at at your age at
seventh like lamborghini it's 17.
wait you're you're telling me you want
me to get a lamborghini yes
why yeah because my mom it'll pay for
itself so many times
my mom let me drive her car the first
day crash it
why would that's not that doesn't have
anything to do with the car yes because
i would probably crash a lamborghini
that does but that's not upon the car
that's upon the driver yeah yeah
wow honestly i think you should get a
lambo and i think you should probably
can't believe you're telling me this
yeah probably
the best car for you to get i would say
is a used huracan at like
150. finance it um keep it like a year
or two
you'll you'll sell it at a minimal loss
like your ownership cost for that car
over two years might be like 30 grand
and what year what year
is the hurricane how old will it be when
i buy i can get a newer one you can get
like a 2015 huracan 2016. so you're
saying
buy a 2016 huracan yeah get like a like
a handful you're saying that something
like get one that you think that stands
out yeah yeah yeah
that's dope i i never thought like i
would love to have a lamborghini but i
just think it's such a bad no no no
you can mark it okay i think it's crazy
yeah for your content
i think you would actually make a ton of
money from that all right guys lambo
coming in the future
you're spending 15 dollars a year to own
a lamborghini like that
and you're definitely uh two videos
video of me getting it yeah paid off
yeah
buying it honestly buying a lamborghini
huracan at 17 17
yeah because of graham stefan even if
you like get an offender bender or
something that's probably worth it
you're encouraging me to crash the car
are you going no
i'm not saying he's like yo crap i'm not
saying anything
when i crash it i'm calling you right
away i'm calling you first you don't
want you don't want to crack it because
here's the because then it's on the
insurance and my dad is going to get it
right um feel bad for me
already diminish the value you should
you should listen to uh the carter
sharer podcast that we had
we had him on and he basically gave us
the reasons why he how he justified
getting a lambo out i was like yeah
that's that's key to you like he spent
literally everything he said he didn't
have enough money he had to wait until
uh them youtube ads youtube adsense came
through wow i wouldn't be able to pay
for the car
because it was literally she was like
back then like he did not have enough
money until he got paid for that month
when did he get a lambo when he was like
he has one i thought stephen his brother
was the one who got the lamborghini no
they like went both in on it oh the
gallardo oh it was their first lambo
that they got
so they both typically owned that one
yeah well that one was huge they got
that like a million subscribers right
like that when steven hit a million
subscribers and car didn't even have a
channel yet
but i was like dude like because when i
like when they were at a million subs i
knew who they were and everything so
and i was like i think around a million
subs at the same time too i was like how
are they affording a lambo like
how are they making so much money like
like i was like no way they have the
same amount of stuff from me but they
can buy a lambo like that is something
they spend everything they have that was
literally every last penny and it paid
for itself like ten times over yeah
yeah because they were like same thing
yeah they were like one of the first
people to like
because they started that that was like
three or four years ago huh yeah
i think there's there's probably very
few things that you'll make more money
and it's
right off especially if i just drive it
yeah and it's a write-off sounds good
driving lamborghini into high school
really yeah really when you think about
it
imagine 30 30 grand over two years let's
even call it 40 thousand it's not gonna
be forty thousand
over two years after taxes it's really
only gonna be like 27
25 000 net over two years i guarantee
you'll be able to make
100 at least 100 000 i did a video where
i drove a lamborghini to
high school yeah and then the same day i
did it on skipping school
to drive a lamborghini and those videos
i killed it they did so well like they
have over a million views yeah there you
go
yeah yeah so and then you could mod the
like this month though you could yeah oh
yeah
this one cpm yeah and in the write-off
you want the tax credit for this year
uh you you could what why not save it
for next year because you get the tax
rate off immediately now
otherwise if you if you buy it in
january you're going to have to wait a
year
next year yeah but that's one of the
best ways carter's been scaling his
income it's just like continuously
buying really nice cars like he bought
like a hummer
and he bought like yeah i've been to his
house multiple lamborghinis yeah
you know how much room did he say how
much his house cost a month to run like
40 grand
yeah but that's so good for his house
because the house like over 20 million
dollars yeah i don't think he needs
that house in ballet i i think yeah the
same effect
in the valley for half the cost 100 but
i think
if they want that location that they got
an insane deal on that house for it
being worth over 20 million and they're
someone's renting it
then for only forty thousand dollars
what's the market that's the market
value yeah
those homes don't rent that well yeah
the guys definitely because the values
in the land
i was talking to like real estate agent
that was there when i was there uh he
said
like the mortgage the guy's paying like
over 60 grand a month or something like
that so the guy's like losing 20 grand a
month
which is insane why would he do that why
would someone want to do that
uh usually those people do
is they'll keep the homes rented while
they pull plants and permits and stuff
like that to eventually tear the house
down and build that's what they're doing
i heard they're building they're gonna
because i don't know if you've seen this
house but
like the whole left side or kind of
depending on which way you look at it is
like
like kind of the butler's yeah and like
it's
so unusable yeah it's like really weird
so yeah
no so that like that house is just it
needs to be torn down
and you're gonna build something brand
new and sell it for like 50 60 million
dollars
so it makes sense they'll rent it to him
he could do whatever he wants to the
house
they don't care and then when plant
plants and permits are ready
and they want to start building it then
he'll leave so at least now they're
making money whereas otherwise they
would
i can't wait i want to text my dad and
tell him that i'm getting a lambo
i'll be like great the financial yeah
graham the financial youtuber is telling
me to get a lambo i
never thought this day would come i
thought he would roast me for getting
the tesla and wasting my money on that
i mean tesla definitely smartest car
and lambo easily i would just see this
as you spending
let's say 1500 a month on
good content uh-huh guaranteed you're
gonna make it back
jesus branding fun too and then you
could also
how much it cost to own a lamborghini at
17. just
because everything at 17 is your is your
point like
if you say this at 30 no one cares you
say it at 17.
it can also get you to a new audience as
well yeah all right when i get the lambo
i'm facetiming you guys first i'm gonna
be like you guys are the reason i own
this
i'm happy i would love to get a lambo
but i just don't think it was a smart
financial decision no i think in your
case
yeah the roi and that would probably be
higher than if i were to put that money
into a house because the video for
college
literally i think you would make more
money that's exactly what carter said he
said
he talked to his accountant and his
accountant said that like it makes sense
for him to continuously buy
all these crazy business expenses
because his roi is insane relative to
what he could be getting in the market
yeah even in those this crazy bull
market for anyone else it's it's
horrible
but those people are not making videos
to post on youtube that make thousands
of dollars each so would you get a lambo
no because it's not just you know yeah
yeah no
in my videos honestly the the best
videos that i've done are
me just sitting in front of a camera
yeah every single time i've spent money
on a video
they don't do well aside from this yeah
i did i didn't buy the tesla though for
a video
that was not none of that was planned
for a video in that ben mal video or
something is one of your biggest ones
yeah yeah well okay so i spent money on
that but that was a trip down oh no that
doesn't really count
that was now it was like 600 bucks
that's nothing compared to what you made
off the video
right like pocket change right but i saw
his house
later the day i got arrested i drove by
it because we were driving to go film it
and i was like
my friend i was with i was like i think
ben malo i feel like he lives right
around team up with him
yeah i would love to film something with
him yeah i watch all his videos now team
up with him
and uh i think go go to his instagram
ben mala and yeah that's his camera guy
i tried to hit him up and no one
responded on instagram yeah then
while i was in florida yeah and they
didn't respond try to try it again yeah
um
because i think in the last few months
his uh camera guy has taken over his
instagram
okay try that try his why is he on
youtube like
what is he trying like he makes so much
money why does he need youtube that's
what i don't understand um
i think he just enjoys it i think yeah i
think he likes to see the reason that's
what i was thinking
when you have that much money like
what's next yeah exactly you want to
just keep doing more details
when i was really big into the car
community all these guys had mega money
and it seems like once they make all the
money what's next after that
then it's like social media clout i have
an idea if you have money you want fame
if you have fame you want money that's
true
that is so true what happens if you have
both i i think that
oh my gosh like i don't know that's a
hard question nobody can answer that one
yeah jeez then it's just fun
i made it like yeah let me just kick
back and sleep
it would be nice to sleep i haven't
slept in a while do you like what's your
work schedule like is it crazy
right when i go out to when i come out
here to film it's crazy like i like i'm
constantly filming all day long like i
barely get to sleep like i finished
filming yesterday like one or two in the
morning
and one and then woke up at six but i
didn't go to bed like two
and like it's been like that for like
the past like four days that i've been
here
so i'm drained you may as well you may
as well you have an opportunity
yeah everything you you make and save
now is going to be worth like
20 times in the future what do you
recommend i do with the money i don't
have invested
you the money you don't have invested
yeah like i have money like i have
probably 200 thousand dollars not
invested in anything honestly i would
just i would just roth ira no sorry roth
i would just index fund it really
honestly like
for you i think managing property is
probably not worth your time if you get
a good property manager i'm all for it
i think just throw it in the stock
market and it's just a good index fund
don't even think about it i think
your money maker right now is just
making more content so i would not your
income yeah definitely
so i wouldn't even think about anything
else just something really simple like
that
something you don't look at you don't
touch just automatically throw like 50
grand a month
into that and then just the rest
reinvest back into the channel
yeah because i i keep my expenses super
low like
i literally won't spend uh money if i
don't need to like it like hurts to
spend money
on like stupid stuff like i'd rather
like starve and wait to the end of the
day to get free food than just
waste some money on like especially uber
eating oh my god like that's
i hate doing that but sometimes you
gotta especially when you're out here
there's not much you can do because
you're so go go but yeah
yeah but yeah that's what i would do but
i don't think it's worth your time to do
anything too time intensive like
you're talking about like doing these
stock trades and like yeah um
i like that that's fun like when i'm
back home i like to focus on how is your
trades
because you're telling me you gotta you
got an alert from him yeah i mean
he does have some good signals and stuff
like that but like i don't know it's a
lot to deal with so i don't like fully
but i i spent five days with him and no
i spent three days with him in new
jersey and
i kind of like shadowed him and like
kind of did some of his trades and stuff
like that and
it was cool to like see what he does but
you do question a lot of stuff but i
mean he he has a mclaren and stuff like
that he's killing it honestly like he
makes a lot of money but
he shows up why is he killing it why is
he killing it is it because
the group oh he definitely makes a lot
of money off the group but he does
make a lot of money on his trades like
he shows the proof and everything so i
mean
i don't know so what exactly do you just
follow his signals you pay him how much
is the monthly or whatever i think it's
like 200
but he let me in for free just because a
guy promoted his stuff before and
everything in
that one that one it turned out yeah we
probably got to wrap up in like few
minutes
we'll just do these two okay yeah um
okay so you
he let you in for free and he just sends
out signals and all you do is just like
open up the signals and just like yeah
follow him yeah pretty much
like he'll be on like voice chat or
something like kill doesn't that just
drive up the price
why everyone is buying in the same
things i mean how many i think you can
help it you know
yeah but but doesn't that make him look
good that no matter what he picks if he
says
i'm gonna think this blue color is gonna
go up no he does like the big socks he
just like like tesla like amazon so like
it doesn't
yeah affect the share but like well he
has like 500 people
or something in his discord that's not
exactly influence that's what i'm saying
yes there's no point of him to
yeah 100 that's why i don't think it
affects it at all and what's your
return on investment been through this
like what's
i mean not much because i haven't really
thought a lot of his trades recently
like i've been like
i kind of stopped with like the options
trading because like
it's hard to like see it go down and
like you get scared so you kind of want
to sell it's like ice and not like
a good test on this thing but he does
have good trades that he profits he
makes a lot of money on
what he does you just have it's like a
lot in the mind you know you have to
like want to
like not sell it you know and just hand
it to yourself yeah it's
so hard it's dangerous what's his name
bia hez or something yeah
he is good at that like not panic
selling like he's so good at holding and
like
it always works out for him it's insane
you like piazza yeah he's awesome he is
cool he's so cool yeah he'd be a good
person to link up with yeah have you met
him in person
no okay you should yeah that'd be dope
you'd be interested in that
yeah okay because he's young too right
he's like 19 19 yeah
he would be a great person to link up
with and just chat with yeah
yeah definitely i like talking to people
that like
have a similar mind to me and now are
like in
in the youtube phases just like kind of
blow their money and not really care
because i know people that
oh my god i know people that are younger
than me that have like
insane amounts of following and like
everyone in their family has access to
their money and like
they just they all post nights like
three things a day for every single meal
gosh like i was uh with this one kid a
couple months ago and they would go to
starbucks every single morning and
literally spend like 50 to 70
or more than that i was like bro graham
would not like that
right yeah right now i make myself eggs
in the morning
smart yeah yeah do you have any other
questions or any advice for us
because i mean you're doing so well at
17 i mean i'm sure that there's
something we could take away from you
i don't know stay young or i'm saying i
don't know don't get arrested don't get
arrested
don't be stay in this lane this is
the money maker lane right here yeah
longevity definitely how long have you
been doing
youtube like seriously like youtube like
youtube seriously three and a half years
so similar to what i've been doing yeah
and we're pretty much at like the same
amount of subscribers right
i'm a little less than you what are you
at 2.6
yeah but you're growing really fast yeah
yeah
so always meet kevin right yep he's
getting carried he's going to hit a
million next week
really yeah congratulations kevin
congratulations yeah
that's a big one yeah do you ever feel
like you're going to burn out or do you
think that your hibernation is when
you're going back to like yeah that
definitely helps me like the
hibernations but i still film like all
but it's just like not as like when i'm
here like i need to film every single
day and like non-stop like otherwise i
don't feel productive and i feel like
i'm wasting my time
so to get it like and that's why like i
don't really sleep much when i'm out
here but any
that i feel like takes such a toll on me
and i really think i'm about to burn out
and like right by the time i get back
home
like cranky and everything i just want
to go back and just
i'm so glad i'm done with it and just
like chill for a couple days because
working non-stop for like a week or two
like literally
sleeping four hours a night like
especially like being young like just
kills you like it literally kills you
like
you feel like you're falling apart
you're like what am i doing like and
i don't know definitely takes a toll on
me but it feels great to be back and
like be done with it you know
like the feeling of filming and having a
good day of filming like knowing that
you're done with it
is like such a good like you can't beat
that it gives you like an adrenaline
rush kind of like
just like knowing that like you're
satisfied with your day and you've got
everything that you could have gotten
done done and it just feels
so nice like i don't think it's so hard
to relate to that unless you're like in
this
you know yeah my favorite is when you
upload a video
you finish the title and thumbnail and
you get it scheduled
and that's my favorite and you and
you're done there's nothing else you
could do yeah i filmed
literally seven videos not just for my
channel but like i filmed three videos
from my channel yesterday
uh my editor sent me the video i had to
review it upload it do the thumbnail
and then while it was uploading before i
did the thumbnail i filmed another video
for my channel
and then right when i finished filming
after you i did the thumbnail posted it
and then on the way here
i put it on the premiere and then yeah
so it just felt nice to be done with
everything
yeah oh awesome cool and we should round
out 40. geez okay cool um so
thank you so much for coming on thank
you so much for having me this has been
awesome i'm sure we'll have you on again
when you get the lamborghini when i get
the lamborghini i'm gonna drive it from
new york to here huh yeah
that's like some miles on that thing
yeah that's a great video surprising
grabs definitely with my lamborghini
and seeing what he says about it graham
reacts to my lamborghini yeah
so we'll have you back on at some point
and you should you could tell like a
video on your second channel or whatever
channel
be like why i told him to buy a
lamborghini because that shocks me and i
watch all your music i can't believe
you're good
i can't believe you see how much money
you make from that is nuts i'm gonna be
i'm looking at lamborghinis as soon as i
happen to be
i'm like i'm gonna get used to use
turrican you're probably
under 160. are those five doors
the doors don't go off actually if
you're gonna get a lamborghini i don't
you need
no because the v12s the maintenance is
too high because the only one that you
can you can add butterfly doors to it
no you don't want to do that why not no
because it's a huracan you don't want
people to know
okay no because otherwise you're getting
a murcielago the maintenance on those is
going to be
ridiculous yeah uh huracan is going to
be a better car
it's more reliable it's more audi and um
otherwise you're going with an aventador
and that's
minimum going to be like 200 and
something grand you're going to get
95 percent the same thing with a huracan
yeah don't care they don't care if it's
a hurricane or an aventador it's just
it's a lamborghini so yeah get the lambo
get the lambo i can't believe i
can't believe you're saying that but
let's go i'm down there we go so
with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
as always make sure to subscribe hit the
notification bell add us on instagram
get your four free stocks
down below in the description thank you
so much for watching and until next time
all right i'm calling my dad to let him
know that i'm buying a lamborghini
according to graham here hold that call
that this side that's the receiver side
what's up hey dad so you know that
you're on speaker right now we're
recording
okay um so basically uh you know how i
was on the
i was doing the podcast with the like
the financial youtuber
yes yeah so he convinced me to get a
lamborghini
what oh he says he's gonna do that what
that'd be crazy why ah it's just too
much money so much of your portfolio
well
what is your reasoning hey as soon as
you buy that lamborghini because now
they're valued
no you buy it used so it only loses like
30 grand over two years and i make
videos on it and it's a good investment
what the what is wrong are you smoking
pot today uh i don't know are you
no dad i promise it's a good instigation
he said it's a good investment
he said it was you sound too good dad no
i promise you dad i promise you
like he was being 100 serious i was on
the same boat you are
but he literally is saying buy a
lamborghini i'm not even joking
yeah he's trying to sell you his
lamborghini no he doesn't have a
lamborghini because
he wouldn't make videos on it but i
would and it would make me more money
yeah no you'll you'll be dead in like a
week yeah that's probably that's what i
was saying
you need you need something that self
tries yep tesla
i agree maybe in the future maybe next
week past year
yeah a penguin but you spend too much
time on the computer to be a good driver
that's true too much time on the couch
you're good at making money not driving
that's true so i'll try so how you doing
how's the podcast go
good i'll call you back after i love you
i love you
dang so no lamborghini huh so it's it's
it's from the perspective
though because i think he'll understand
the financials of it when you when you
get when
you watch the podcast i've watched the
podcast show him carter carter's segment
yeah yeah
because you'd be able to convince him on
the financial aspect 100 if he's worried
about the safety aspect
that's another thing i mean that's we
can't go into that i can convince him to
let me do anything honestly
like it's just the safety aspect that's
the only thing
because then because now also if
anything happens to you in a lamborghini
that's going to be knocking on your door
so if
you get the lambo you have to be like so
careful with that yeah
i'll drive you because yeah i mean he's
right you got to be a good driver to do
that
but you know what you can also do is pay
for racing school there are schools that
you can pay like seven grand for
and it's literally to teach you how to
handle those high performance cars in
any situation
um and you can make video on that like
that would pay for itself
you get lamborghini training yeah uh
what is it like bondurant or like one of
those uh racing schools uh-huh yeah
they're like seven grand
it's like a two day thing where they
teach you on a race track how to handle
these cars hey i'm gonna get a
lamborghini
i'm going to but just make sure it's the
safety aspect i'll be responsible on
that yeah i'll wear a helmet
no driving school i can't go that can't
be going to any school right now no way
we're like we're like knee pads yeah
knee pads bubble wrap
yeah like literally when i watched dude
that would be hilarious that's a video
that is so good driving lamborghini in
bubble wrap yeah yeah
there's so many things really having my
dad like grab me bubble wrap i'll be
like damn i'm gonna go drive the land
but you'd be like wait
like bubble wrapping on the elbows knee
pads yeah put on your suit everything
like ten sweatshirts like everything on
top of it just as much padding as
possible yeah but show them show them
this and i'll be uh
we'll be talking to dad here i mean the
safety thing aside you know you know
your son better than than we do
but uh safety aside financially the
huracans are not gonna go down in value
very little they hold their value really
well you just gotta buy smart if you if
you buy these cars at the right price
really you could almost break even on
them within about 18 months
so i'm actually taking depreciation to
an extreme over two years
you buy it at 1 65 170
it's probably going to be worth
realistically about 145 to 150 by the
time you're done with it
so you're losing very little money the
only money you're going to lose is
minimal depreciation
sales tax depending on where you
register the car insurance
gas repairs are very minimal on that
because it's really it's you're buying
an audi r8
really is what you're buying on that car
uh which are pretty reliable so you're
not going to have a lot of issues you do
a pre-purchase inspection it's not going
to cost you much
the content you could get from this it's
like two videos a month
on a lamborghini well so much
everything i do with my tesla with my
lamborghini yeah it's like double the
video lamborghini has a clickability
factor on youtube
and the only and you combine lamborghini
with 17
and that's that is this winning
combination because once you get into
like your 20s
it does not have the same effect to have
a lamborghini then it becomes a little
like oh what's this kid doing
yeah but 17 you have this small window
of 17 lamborghini that is just it hits
all right i guess i'm putting i'm
putting this clip in my video of me
buying lamborghini
to justify it but be safe be safe
yeah you have to drive the speed limit
no racing no
doing anything crazy on your phone when
you're driving yeah no no
nothing like that yeah definitely not so
sounds good i'm excited to go
let's go come on i'll say yeah okay wait
hold on so are we going to introduce
this
30th to the 31st are we doing strat
management we we said we were going to
use shroud man first
okay so we'll do this one as the 31st
episode 31st ever
so basically you're just going to say
like this uh welcome to the
31st ever episode of the iced coffee
hour you need the ever
in there and then we have made
approximately i have it i screenshotted
it in my photos
um three three
five nine twenty three three five nine
so twenty three thousand
three hundred hundred and fifty nine on
the podcast all right so
i say welcome to the thirty first ever
episode of the
iced coffee hour my name is jack doherty
yeah and we've made twenty three
thousand
three hundred and fifty nine dollars
yeah
all you could say doll hairs and make
sure you say ever
yeah ever okay ready okay oh and then
look into
that one right there that one's just on
you okay
wait how do i started welcome to the
thirty-first i've ever said